i guarantee that this video right here
will be the best 3d floor plan video
you've ever seen on youtube and just to
prove how casually serious i am i put on
a cuts polo
just for this video
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas welcome back to the channel today
we're talking about 3d architectural
floor plans and what you need to do to
produce some of the best in the industry
now we could easily go through this
using an old floor plan but i want to go
through this from start to finish with
you guys showing you exactly what you
need to be thinking of as you're
actually developing those plans so you
don't have to go back and waste a hell
of a lot of time redoing work for no
reason
we're going to be starting with archicad
25 and moving over to twin motion to
produce the best quality we possibly can
now without further ado let's turn
around to these two screens and get on
with today's video so like always we
start with the australian select
template again feel free to use whatever
template is available to you and in your
country
i personally use archicad 25 as
my program of choice because i know
archicad the best it's what i use day in
day out as an architect here in western
australia
once icad 25 is open we really want to
start thinking about the fundamentals of
our design so we're creating a 3d floor
plan which means we're thinking about
the materials the textures the spaces
and everything surrounding that building
so let's start by pressing command 7 to
open up our story settings inserting a
story below
typing in footings and dropping that
down minus
172 millimeters that allows us to create
a footings layer and actually start
creating our slabs which might be our
carpet or tiles or anything in between
so let's click ok double click on our
ground floor plan and let's just make
something very simple nothing overly too
complex so let's start by using generic
wall we're going to go to our walls
external for something different because
you guys know i like to go with the stud
frame let's go a brick veneer with an
insulated stud panel now all i'm going
to do is simply start drawing an outline
of a building the first click and then
i'm going to click p to flip my wall by
holding shift and pressing d i'm able to
actually start typing in some numbers
instead so let's go 5 meters 5 meters 5
meters
10 meters
15 meters maybe two and a half meters ah
three meters back five more meters
and then i'm just gonna align it to
create the outside of what my building
is gonna be now i have absolutely no
idea what i'm creating i'm just
genuinely going with the flow to show
you guys what we need to be thinking
about throughout the entire process so
as you can see we've used a brick veneer
wall system so brick on the outside
timber on the inside if we come to our
3d window you'll see that straight away
we have our materials and our textures
shown up if i was to create a 3d floor
plan of this you would see the bricks
and you would see some sort of gray
interior now this is where we have to
start thinking about the process and
start thinking logically do we want any
feature wall panels where's the bed head
where's the tiles gonna go what sort of
things actually are happening on those
walls themselves or are they just
plasterboard so let's just go back to
our ground floor plan open up our
object tool and let's just drop a bed in
so we can start manipulating and moving
some spaces around and understanding
scale
i'm not going to go ahead and change all
these settings i'm just simply going to
change that to a black outline because i
hate the green
and i'm going to change the objects to
general so now as you can see we have
our bed let's pop our bed over here that
looks like a reasonable size bedroom if
not even an overkill so what i'll
actually do is now start drawing another
wall internally with a brick veneer
we're going to be using our 90
millimeter stud internal petition so i'm
going to draw one wall here and by
pressing command d moving that down
let's call it 1400 millimeters so we can
insert a row behind again command d to
drag our object and changing the
position of our bed i'm going to hold
the alt button to start creating a new
timber wall
and drag it all the way to the end so
now coming back into 3d you'll see
we've started to create our actual
spaces we have our bedroom we have our
robe and we have our main living spaces
over here i'll start to manipulate this
outside wall as well so command d and
dragging it in line with our other wall
selecting our three exterior walls and
pressing command i to join them and then
just realigning those walls so we have a
little bit of freedom i'm going to hold
the alt button and use this space here
to create our bathroom now i'm hoping
that this is about two meters deep at
1890 is probably okay it's not the best
but it will do for now so what i'm gonna
do is duplicate this bed come across and
type in shower now icat in general
doesn't really have very good
shower objects at all so i'm just going
to use this shower cabin for the
purposes of this video and drop it in to
where i think it needs to be i will
extend it significantly larger so it
goes across the whole space duplicate it
once more find a vanity and click ok
so
as you can see i'm starting to create
the actual bathroom layout space and
finally all we need is a bathtub for
this shower to be complete now if i
rotate that to position drag it all the
way over here drag it in line
then i can utilize this additional space
on the other side for a toilet so let's
copy that across once more and create a
toilet any toilet for the purpose of
this will absolutely be fine
so once again we're just going to drag
that center that 450
and make a new wall one meter away so as
you can see now we have our bathroom we
have our bedroom and we have most of our
living spaces again absolutely no idea
what this is going to look like in the
end i'm genuinely just plotting spaces
where they think they should go and as
you can see we have the fundamentals of
our room so because this is our wet area
what i'd like to do is actually cut this
wall using the axe tool
so it splits in two different directions
and then do the same with the exterior
wall here so i've done that for a
specific reason i can now select these
two outside walls go command t to open
up their settings change the interior
surface to tiles 15 by 15 and click ok
as you can see that material texture has
changed very quickly very rapidly to
something very different so we can
manipulate that in twin motion a little
bit later on with this partition wall
i'm going to change both the interior
the and the exterior
to tiles 15 to match those tiles over
there and with the bathroom toilet wall
i'm going to simply just change the
interior wall to tiles 15. finally i'll
repeat that process for this hallway
wall to the interior as well tiles 15
and okay now we have our bathroom which
is floor to ceiling tiles in all the wet
areas our bedrooms for example
don't need to be anything like this they
can simply be stratco
white rough or stratco white fine will
do it doesn't really matter because
we're going to be changing the materials
in twin motion but we want it to have a
unique color when saying that i'm simply
going to go across and
paint that titanium white and click ok
so that i know i've changed these
bedroom walls to white titanium
then i'm actually going to change this
feature wall to some sort of nice
vertical mahogany timber so we have our
feature wall in our bedroom now i do
know that twin motion has much much
better objects than this so we might
actually replace these objects in twin
motion as we work through this tutorial
coming back to our ground floor plan
what we're going to need to do is
actually introduce a hallway so let's
extend that by 1200 to create a hallway
and merge these spaces here this might
be a storeroom it might be a scullery it
might be a boot room it might even be a
spare bathroom which would make logical
sense
to keep all our wet areas in the same
space so what i might actually do is
simply copy this toilet across and copy
this hand basin across as well making
that only 1500 wide so we have a little
bit of space
and then i'll extend my hallway all the
way across
now to make better use of this space and
actually make it uh ensuite rather than
just a standalone bathroom i'll extend
this wall here 1200 millimeters back
join those two walls there and extend
our main wall now because i know this
wall here has the same settings as this
i'm simply going to copy that across
and i'm then also going to cut
my wall in line with the bathroom so
that i can change the internal materials
to just tiles as you can see the
formation of this bathroom now doesn't
make any logical sense it doesn't work
with what we're trying to achieve so
what i'm going to do is i'm actually
going to change this back to a one meter
by one meter shower and rotate it around
so now if i place my shower in line with
the corner and adjust the rest of my
room accordingly i can actually start to
gain a little bit of extra unrequired
space now coming back into our 3d you'll
see again everything shift a little bit
we have our tiles missing from that wall
so i'll simply just merge those two
walls by pressing command i
this wall over here definitely does not
need to be
tiles at all so i'll take both of those
walls and i'll paint them white titanium
to match the bedroom walls like we have
over here this wall being on the inside
of the hallway i will change again so it
matches to white titanium
now like i said earlier on in the video
it is very important that we're thinking
about these textures these materials
these ideas as we're actually drawing
and as we're creating because the more
time we spend now changing these
materials the less time it's going to
take us in twin motion you'll see that
this part of the tutorial will take up
probably about 75 percent of the time
whilst the twin motion section will take
25 percent if not even less if you take
into account all my rambling non-stop in
between these sections now coming back
to the ground floor plan i've created a
dead amount of space over here which we
absolutely don't need so let's delete
both of those there
extend our wall with tiles all the way
across extend our wall with no tiles all
the way across so that we can create
some sort of entryway now let's
duplicate this hand basin and start
typing in our
actual living amenities so we've got a
sofa which we can implement anywhere in
our design this will most likely be our
kitchen i'd assume somewhere over here
would be our lounge and this will
probably be a one-bedroom alfresco
so again
huge huge space overkill entirely for
the design we're going for so we're
going to continue to reduce it as we go
through
so let's simply just create a small
little lounge room over here that might
be utilized in everyday life okay so we
have three little couches i'm also going
to create a slab which i'm just going to
go user defined open up those settings
change that to
500 millimeters which will be i don't
know some sort of tv unit in this
instance
i'll probably just leave it as a plywood
for the time being and overwrite all
those materials to pine horizontal works
really well for me
and then i'm going to create a 450x21
tv unit
centering it in line with our couch
finally i'm just going to create a tv
that i can mount on the wall there we go
i have a flat panel tv rotated 180
degrees
mount it directly on the wall and center
it to our couch again so it actually
makes some sort of logical sense this tv
unit is going to drive me crazy if i
leave it in blue so i will change it to
black and then what i'll do is simply
replicate
that two times once for a rug
once for a coffee table so let's go 1200
by 1200
that could be our coffee table in the
middle i'm going to make this only 10
millimeters and 10 millimeters above
zero
simply changing that to carpet 0 1 for
the time being coming back into our 3d
to see how we're coming along and as you
can see we need to lift our tv unit and
our tv
so they're actually sitting in a much
nicer space as well as our tv unit
which is hidden underneath our carpet i
will reduce that one down to about 300
so it is a little bit smaller than our
tv unit but as you can see now our
fundamental basics are starting to come
into effect and we're starting to create
our floor plan in 3d as we're really
looking
for that impact that wow factor at the
end of the day now that we have our
living room we're going to need our
dining room which is always very very
simple because our cat has
some pretty decent objects for dining
room you just simply type in table not
dining scroll down to the rectangular
table arcade25 that will do for now
clicking ok and dragging it into the
position it needs to be now i've just
noticed that our bathroom still doesn't
work so what i'm going to do is simply
remove
that wall
and switch out my bathtub and my toilet
location so the toilet isn't in its own
little space but it's in that main
ensuite space to create our kitchen i'm
not going to focus on cabinetry or
anything like that i'm simply just going
to draw a 600 deep bench top making that
900 high and 900 deep i'm going to
create that out of pure concrete and
repeat the same process
one meter ahead here with a 300
millimeter overhang now that overhang is
only going to be about 100 millimeter
thick concrete instead of the full 900
so you can actually get some sort of
bar stool under it and there you go we
have our concrete bench on this side our
concrete bench on this side a nice
little dining room over here a lot of
dead space that we could definitely just
start adjusting as we see fit so that we
don't have a lot of dead space for
absolutely no reason in this design now
i do want to quickly point out that this
design has absolutely nothing to do with
actually designing something in archicad
it's more so to show you the actual
floor plan process and what you need to
be aware of as you're designing so again
that has now changed its wall texture so
we need to make sure the textures are
correct overall that works relatively
well i think we need to import a couple
appliances into our kitchen and then
we're more or less ready to take this
into twin motion we just need to pop a
couple windows in and a few doors as
well so let's simply start by
introducing a sink into our project this
sink will do for the time being i'm
going to place that
smack bang
in the middle of this concrete bench
then i'm gonna look for a cooktop
placing that on the opposite side of the
bench in the corner over here second
last we're gonna need a fridge this 17
side-by-side refrigerator will do so
we'll just download and import that into
our archicad project now i'm not really
sure where the 25 object is i'm sure it
is somewhere it's probably called
something completely different for a
dumb reason i use personally the 4d
library for the fridges and objects
cooktops things like that
so i'm not 100 familiar with the native
archicad
options for this
now i'm going to introduce my fridge
here on the side move that 120
millimeters so i can actually return
that side wall
and bring the bench all the way across
finally i'm just gonna create a small
pantry on the right hand side and that's
pretty much it for space and what we
need as you can see we've introduced a
very yellow fridge i'm just quickly
going to
change all of that to stainless steel
and click ok so it isn't this
horrendously ugly looking thing now as
you can see we are missing our floor
textures we're missing our materials so
we want to go back to our ground floor
press control down
right click on our ground and go show as
trace reference so now we're drawing on
our footings layer we're creating the
actual floor content itself from tiles
to carpet to vinyl flooring and
everything in between we're really
looking to create that here and now
so simply by opening the slab tool once
again and pressing command t we can
start changing it up we're going to
start with a hundred millimeters thick
we're gonna go to concrete structural
because that's what it is
and let's start with carpet in the
bedroom i used carpet one on this rug so
i want to use a different carpet
material for this space here
next i'm going to draw the space through
the bathroom and
change that to tiles white 15 by 15 so
it matches the wall tiles and finally
this space here i believe is going to be
some sort of timber flooring so let's go
light oak for the time being and if we
wanted to create a little veranda over
here we could once again copy that and
change that to concrete so if we come
into our 3d view you see now that all of
these floors need to be lifted 172
millimeters which was our command 7
story settings that we adjusted and
we now have the fundamental basics of
what we need for a 3d floor plan all i
would add to this is a simple mesh on
the ground floor so if we go to our slab
go to our mesh and start creating some
spaces in between let's make this grass
perfect
and then i'm just going to introduce a
driveway
there make sure that's only about four
meters cutting it out of
that green landscaping space
redefining it as concrete so that our
materials and textures are correct
coming back into 3d we'll see that our
floor plan is starting to come together
now i do want this to be perfectly
symmetrical all around so i'm going to
make that 10 meters
i'm going to make that i'm going to make
this side again 10 meters and repeat it
all the way around now if we come back
into 3d perfectly centered into this
floating little 3d floor plan space all
we need to do now is come back into our
ground floor plan and start introducing
some doors and windows so simply by
clicking on door door 25 we have a
standard door we might want it to look a
little bit nicer so let's change up the
doors and start introducing them where
we actually need them i'm just going to
keep clicking through we probably don't
need
too many doors in this actual project
here so we'll need two doors either side
of the bed so we can
make our walk-in robe over here that is
one thing i didn't do i didn't actually
create any cabinetry so let's start by
introducing this
walk-in robe system here and coming back
into 3d it just gives us a little bit
more character to play with and now that
that's basically all the doors we need
in this project it is pretty limited we
can actually create one more door here
as the entrance statement door so if we
wanted to change that up we could make
it a nice big glass french door that one
will do let's make it 1200 wide so it's
a nice statement piece and 2 4 high
so it definitely looks different to all
the doors in our project and if we fly
around you'll see that doors come into
place next we want to make sure all our
internal walls that need to be
plasterboard are the same material so
once again coming back into our
materials going to titanium white
pressing ok
and all our painted white plasterboard
materials are now the same texture
coming back into our ground floor plan
let's go into our window settings open
our window settings
and start introducing a couple different
windows
let's use that window over here
i'm not really too worried about what
the windows are what they look like
or anything of that sort i'm just merely
introducing windows for the sake of
windows next i'd like a sliding glass
door to both our patio and our outdoor
space in our bedroom so i'll go into
sliding i will find our nice double
external sliding doors i'll introduce
them here and i'll also introduce them
here so i would like to make these 2 4
high exactly the same as our main door
and i'll probably make them about 2 4
wide because what they are now is a
little bit too small for my personal
preference moving them into place coming
back into our 3d view you'll see that we
have all the doors and windows in place
now again i don't like the orange but i
left them all there on purpose if you
press command f you'll open up our find
and select tool by clicking the copy
settings and then the plus
it's automatically going to highlight
all the doors in the project we can come
to our floor plan marker override object
pen and change that to black
clicking ok repeating the same steps for
the windows themselves we can quickly
and easily change
all of the windows and doors without
having to fumble around and individually
change those line weights now as you can
see we basically have everything we need
except a couple small windows in our
bathroom so let's simply recreate this
some small little window there another
small little window here
and we'll probably adjust them
in the settings together at the same
time
so let's make that a simple panel glass
clicking okay so we don't really have to
worry about them too much i will
probably go in there once more and just
change the material of that glass to
glass satin so we can actually
differentiate those two windows from the
rest of the windows in this project
now what i'm going to do is save this
project install the twin motion plug-in
because i've just realized i don't have
the plugin installed in arcade 25
and jump to twin motion in this tutorial
now i just want to take a quick short
interlude to point out the fact that
there are some great resources in the
description below there's everything
from title blocks for archicad it's a
construction checklist so you know
exactly what needs to go on a page there
is even a fantastic discord group that
is growing every single day with all
sorts of architectural professionals
students and really anybody in the
industry and they are constantly helping
each other out there's question after
question of archicad how do i do this
how do i fix that and without fail
somebody is there to save the day so
that community is fantastic it is
growing so well and i'm so proud of that
little discord chat it is 100 free if
you do want to join it if you want a
copy of the arcade files that i create
on youtube then you can simply join the
patreon link down below and through the
discord group chat you will have access
to every single arcade tutorial i make
on youtube and of course as always there
is the cuts clothing discount link just
below that if you want to grab a good
cuts clothing t-shirt
genuinely you can look back through any
of my videos they are by far one of the
only t-shirts i've ever worn on this
channel they are just truly absolutely
incredible i know they're a bit pricey
but they're 100
worth the price tag
anyway i know that's enough of my face
let's turn back around okay so now that
we've transferred this project over in
to twin motion we can start manipulating
and playing with this 3d floor plan
concept
first of all we want to start using the
materials on the side and actually
utilizing what we have so let's start by
going materials and i always like to
start by changing the actual base of
this to plastic red glossy and changing
that to 100
pure white
clicking okay getting rid of the
reflection entirely that way when we
export it we have a nice clean white
slate to play with
next we want to come in to our man-made
material so ground
man-made and change our
driveway material to a nice concrete
texture then we can go back to our
nature and change our grass to something
a bit more realistic and we're going to
follow that process all the way through
basically replacing all the materials
that archicad has provided with some
really nice unique materials from twin
motion so as you can see that recycled
brick right there is probably a little
bit too small i double that in size and
we have a nice recycled brick
next i'd like to change all the tiles in
the project
so we go into our tiles and i will make
them all generically the same i'll
probably make them something a little
bit darker a little bit moodier and
quite large in scale as well so we
actually have a little bit of texture a
little bit of differentiation in the
project already now i want this wall to
be a nice timber
so i'll use this dark timber go to
scale and rotate that 90 degrees you
probably won't be able to see it until i
zoom in and i'll probably change that
back to zero degrees so it's a vertical
pattern instead of a horizontal one that
gives us a nice little bit of
contrasting material in that bedroom
that we can utilize next we're going to
jump into our kitchen go to our metal
change our fridge to brushed aluminium
do the same and also for our hot plate
now as you can see these are all
flickering and not coming through
correctly so i'll just quickly go back
into arcad and cut these two out now as
you can see that material there is not
cutting through all the way so we're
going to go into settings and we're
going to make that two-sided so we see
that sync in its full entirety if you
ever have a curved object in arcad in
twin motion that doesn't work just
simply make it two-sided now i've also
noticed that i've cut that out way too
much so i'll go back into arcade and fix
that now i have actually removed that
table accidentally i can't be bothered
going back into archicad and adding it
again so i will
just simply go in to our living spaces
find a table look for a nice twin motion
table that's probably even better than
the one we had in archicad this orange
one will do quite nicely give it a
little bit of a color pop next we're
going to come back in and update our
wall material so if we scroll down to
wall coverings and simply drop our
plaster on there we have a little bit
more texture on our wall
we're also going to find a nice
fabric material that we can change these
hideous yellow couches to now i'm a
pretty basic black and white kind of guy
so i will simply pick a nice white
fabric and i'll change that to a little
bit of a darker gray
i'll probably do the same thing with the
actual carpet below so i'll use a nice
light gray shaggy rug and i'll make it a
dark black so as you can see now it's
slowly coming together we're almost
there in what we need to do to actually
create this
final 3d floor plan i do want to also
change the floor itself so i don't like
the floor i'm going to scale it up and i
will rotate this one 90 degrees so the
floor tiles go the other way
i'm going to change my concrete bench to
a nice bare base concrete
and i'm also going to change the
material
off these doors to a nice black brushed
aluminum and the glass finally as well
to a nice reflective glass
so now as you can see we have our 3d
floor plan starting to come into play we
can see all the different materials all
the different textures and we can create
multiple vistas of the same floor plan
so people can actually understand what
we're looking at doing now as you can
see i do have a small little courtyard
out here so maybe we introduce another
small little round table
that can fit out here with some more
beautiful colored furniture now that's
pretty much all we have to do to create
our
actual architectural 3d floor plan we've
introduced all our elements i've
showcased everything that we need to
know in twin motion last but not least
we're going to actually start by
creating our views so let's close that
panel on the side create our first image
so if we click on image
click the plus button and we're going to
start adjusting and changing the
settings because this is how we make it
look really really good
first of all let's go to our camera
settings and change that maybe a 20
millimeter lens and zoom out ever so
slightly so we can see
nothing but green grass now like i said
before i like to keep the white pattern
but in this instance i'm simply going to
drag and drop that grass over the top
and align it 100 with the top of our
grass
so that we don't actually see any white
we just see nice grass the hardest
element of this process is actually
aligning your camera settings now that
i'm happy with my camera settings i'm
going to go back into my image click my
refresh button to refresh that image
exactly how it is go back into more once
again and start adjusting my location
and my lighting to make sure it isn't
overly harsh and
unbearable to see so first of all i'm
going to go into my location let's
change it to perth western australia
just because that is where i am located
adjust our north point to suit us as
best as we need it i think in this case
it would be nice to see the shadows as
they are i'm going to move it to a
summer sun and i'm going to adjust
the actual time of day a little bit as
well
now finally i'm gonna go back into my
image one i'm gonna go to my lighting
and i'm gonna go into my advanced
settings i'm gonna decrease the ambient
lighting requirements to 0.25 so that
all of my materials inside aren't overly
bright i'm also going to increase my sun
intensity to 30 then change my weather
to a little bit cloudy and then that's
basically the first image that we've
created now to make sure this exports
extremely high quality we do want to go
into more format and change it to ultra
4k hd
you can bump that up higher to 8k hd
even 16k
if you do want to let your computer run
overnight a little bit longer i'll
repeat that same process spinning around
to the other side of the house
again the incredibly difficult part of
this is actually just adjusting your
camera settings clicking the create
image and now we have our second image
if i did want to go in here change the
location and adjust that sun in any way
shape or form i could but for the time
being i think the sun kind of works just
fine i'll move that down to about 4 30
so it isn't as bright and glary as it
was before i'll probably change the
lighting in this one to 1630 as well so
the time matches identically i'll go
ahead and create two more images of each
side
and finally i will create one top down
view now the top down view is the
hardest to create because all of your
controls in twin motion go out the
window when you start going top down so
take your time to make sure you get the
top down view correct if you can't get
the top down view perfect like i can't
in this situation you can adjust that in
photoshop lightroom or any other program
that you're efficient in i will once
again just simply change the lighting on
this so it is a little bit different to
all the others
just so we have some 3d texture
happening here now when i'm happy with
that i simply refresh my settings come
down to the export button go image
select all and hit export all right so
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you learned
something today i hope you were able to
get some incredible content for your own
personal portfolio if you did make sure
you smash that like button down below it
genuinely helps with the youtube
algorithm and make sure you hit the
subscribe button believe it or not those
two actions and those two actions alone
will help this video grow so much and
help this channel grow as well anyway
that is all for me today guys so thank
you so much for watching and like always
i'll see you next monday